BOB MUELLER FILES MORE
ININDICTMENTS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION AND THE WHITE
HOUSE IS CHEERING TONIGHT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THE ANGLE.
WE FINALLY HAVE INDICTMENTS IN
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
RELATED TO MEDDLING IN THE 2016
ELECTION.
AND THE ONLY ONES BEING CHARGED
ARE RUSSIANS.
A FEDERAL GRAND JURY HAS NOW
INDICTED 13 RUSSIAN INDIVIDUALS
AND COMPANIES FOR INTERFERING
WITH THE ELECTION.
BUT THEY'RE NOT ACCUSED OF
RIGGING THE ELECTION FOR TRUMP
BUT INSTEAD OF WAGING
INFORMATION WARFARE TO SOW
DISCORD IN THE POLITICAL SYSTEM.
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN ANNOUNCED THE
INDICTMENTS AND ADDED THIS
IMPORTANT CAVEAT.
>> THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS A KNOWING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN THE
INDICTMENT THAT THE CHARGE
CONDUCT ALTERED THE OUTCOME OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> DID YOU HEAR THAT?
NO AMERICAN KNOWINGLY TOOK PART
IN THE MEDDLING.
AND THE PLOT HAD NO EFFECT ON
THE OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION.
THE FACTS, AS WE KNOW THEM RIGHT
NOW, SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT'S
ARGUMENT, AN ARGUMENT WE HAVE
BEEN MAKING ON THIS SHOW FOR
MONTHS, THAT THERE WAS NO
RUSSIAN  COLLUSION.
TRUMP TOOK A BIT OF A VICTORY
LAP, TWEETING TODAY, RUSSIA
STARTED IN 2014, LONG BEFORE I
ANNOUNCED I WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DID NOTHING
WRONG.
NO COLLUSION.
WELL, IT CERTAINLY LOOKS THAT
WAY.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE WHAT
ELSE MUELLER MAY HAVE UP HIS
SLEEVE.
THOUGH, I'LL TELL YOU WHO THIS
TOTALLY VINDICATES.
CONSERVATIVES AND REPUBLICANS
WHO HAVE BEEN WARNING PEOPLE FOR
YEARS ABOUT HOW DEVIOUS THE
RUSSIANS CAN BE IN THIS
SITUATION.
REMEMBER, WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
SARCASTICALLY MOCKED MITT ROMNEY
SARCASTICALLY MOCKED MITT ROMN Y
ROMNEY'S WARNING.
>> WHEN ASKED, YOU SAID RUSSIA.
THE COLD WAR HAS BEEN OVER FOR
20 YEARS.
>> NOW, OBAMA WAS SO CONVINCED
OF THAT, HIS DOJ AND FBI DID
NEXT TO NOTHING ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN SKULDUGGERY.
I LOVE THAT WORD.
HIS DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY APPROVED
THE VISAS FOR THE RUSSIAN
OPERATIVES
OPERATIVES INDICTED BY MUELLER
TODAY.
HIS FBI BEGAN SPYING ON TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ADVISOR PAGE IN THE
FALL OF 2016.
DETAILS OF TODAY'S INDICTMENT DO
POINT TO VINDICATION FOR THE
TRUMP TEAM.
THIS IS JONATHAN TURLEY FROM
TONIGHT'S SPECIAL REPORT.
>> THIS MAKES MORE SENSE.
THIS BEGAN IN 2014, BEGAN BEFORE
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE RUSSIANS WERE TAKING TARGETS
OF OPPORTUNITY AND SHOOTING AT
EVERYBODY IN THE ELECTION BUT
CERTAINLY WORKING MORE AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON.
BUT WHAT IT DOES SHOW IS THAT
THEY DID A REALLY QUITE
IMPRESSIVE JOB IN FINDING THIS
CYBER TRAIL TO THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
>> I'LL SAY.
AND THE INDICTMENT DESCRIBES
RALLIES THAT TOOK PLACE AFTER
THE ELECTION, BOTH IN SUPPORT OF
AND AGAINST TRUMP.
AND BY THE WAY, SOME OF THEM
HAPPENED ON THE SAME DAY, ALL
ALLEGEDLY PROMOTED BY THESE
RUSSIAN ACCOUNTS.
YOU SEE THIS AD?
WELL, ACCORDING TO BUZZFEED,
THIS ANTI-TRUMP RALLIES STAGED
FOUR DAYS AFTER THE ELECTION WAS
PROMOTED BY SOMETHING CALLED
"BLACK MATTERS US."
WHY WOULD TRUMP COLLUDE WITH
RUSSIANS TO STAGE ANTI-TRUMP
RALLIES?
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DID NOT KNOW
ABOUT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN
THE ELECTION.
BUT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY DID AND MAY HAVE IN
FACT ENABLED IT.
GIVEN THAT WE ALREADY KNOW
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC PAID FOR THAT FAKE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, IT'S TIME FOR
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INTERVIEW
HILLARY CLINTON, JOHN KERRY,
SUSAN RICE, BEN RHODES, AND
MAYBE EVEN BARACK OBAMA.